2019 was a great year for movies.
Whether you bought tickets to see a raunchy
tween-starring comedy or a nuanced familial
dramedy, it felt like there was a movie for
everyone.
Here are the very best films of 2019.
Rocketman is not a traditional biopic.
It instead aims to capture the life of the
legendary Elton John through a deft blending
of fact and fantasy.
It's a bold gambit that somehow works swimmingly,
thanks in large part to a brilliant lead performance
from Taron Egerton.
Chicago Reader's Leah Pickett opined that
the fantasy conceit is part of what made the
film work so well.
She wrote:
"This fantastical take...is undoubtedly how
the unconventional artist at its center wanted
it to be.
The story reshuffles reality, especially time
and facts, and the film is more enjoyable
for it."
Many critics were complimentary of Egerton's
performance, but Quad City Times' Linda Cook
summed it up best with a sweet line:
"I hope you don't mind that I put down in
words how wonderful life is when Elton John's
music, and this movie, are in the world."
"Never told you how much I need you."
"No, no, I love you mate."
Fans waited four long years for the ninth
film from Quentin Tarantino, and as usual,
the master delivered a singular and amazing
piece of cinema.
Once Upon a Time in Hollywood is Tarantino's
portrait of the swinging '60s in Los Angeles,
and how they came to an abrupt end the night
of August 8, 1969.
The night that followers of the infamous Charles
Manson visited the house of pregnant actress
Sharon Tate, leaving the town changed forever
in their bloody wake.
Tarantino's story is told through the lens
of fictional washed-up actor Rick Dalton and
his best buddy and stunt double Cliff Booth,
as they find themselves in the middle of the
seismic events of that night.
Praise was effusive for Brad Pitt and Leonardo
DiCaprio's "amazing" onscreen chemistry, and
while not every critic was convinced, Once
Upon a Time in Hollywood was generally found
to stand with Tarantino's best work.
As Lou Thomas of Den of Geek wrote:
"Tarantino has created a storming hangout
movie for the ages: changing times captured
remarkably by a film in love with cinema itself."
"I'm Rick Dalton's stunt double."
"Stuntman."
"Yeah."
"You know, you're kind of pretty for a stuntman."
"That's what they tell me."
Writer/director Ari Aster made a huge noise
in 2018 with his terrifying debut Hereditary,
but in 2019, we discovered that he had just
been warming up.
Midsommar finds troubled couple Dani and Christian
going on a trek through the Swedish countryside
to a remote village.
The bizarre happenings there unfold not in
the dead of night, but in broad, sunny daylight,
one of many unusual aspects of the film which
critics singled out for praise.
Midsommar's underlying themes also packed
a punch, as Dani's grief over a family tragedy
opens the door to a harrowing examination
of our ability to deal with internal struggles.
Salon's Matthew Rosza wrote:
"Midsommar isn't just a great horror movie,
or proof that director Ari Aster is a budding
auteur who likely has a bright future ahead
of him.
It is also one of the best movies ever made
about living with mental illness."
From producer Guillermo del Toro and director
André Øvredal comes the big-screen adaptation
of the beloved childrens' book series Scary
Stories to Tell in the Dark.
The film weaves the series' different stories
together into its spooky tale of a group of
teenagers who discover the lost writings of
a very troubled little girl.
Said writings have a way of leaping right
off the page...literally, as the book's spooky
contents start coming menacingly to life.
Øvredal is no slouch when it comes to bringing
the scares, although, in keeping with its
target audience, the flick was found to be
more spooky than grisly.
But most critics agreed that the director
had notched an admirable achievement.
Chicago Reader's Andrea Gronvall wrote:
"If there ever was a case of a film adaptation
improving on the original source material,
this is it."
In Ready or Not, a new bride is treated to
a murderous game of hide-and-seek at the estate
of her allegedly loving husband's family.
The flick earned stellar reviews, most of
which praised its underlying themes of tension
between the rich and poor, as well as its
deft mix of comedy and jaw-dropping gore.
Said Rolling Stone's Peter Travers:
"What a decadent blast to watch a comic takedown
of the rich done with the rude energy of a
horror thriller and the courage of its own
manic anti-marriage convictions."
Lead actress Samara Weaving's performance
was also singled out for praise early and
often, but the definitive assessment of the
flick was handed down by Allen Adams of The
Maine Edge:
"In Ready or Not, you get a brutal and darkly
funny twist on horror movie tropes.
You'll laugh, you'll cringe...and you'll probably
do both at the same time."
For six seasons, the British period drama
Downton Abbey kept audiences on both sides
of the pond enthralled.
The show ended in 2015, but the feature film
of the same name picked up right from where
it left off.
Make no mistake: Downton Abbey is fan service
of the highest order, and while it might have
left the uninitiated puzzled, the flick was
a welcome gift for longtime viewers.
As Matt Zoller-Seitz of RogerEbert.com wrote:
"The [three and a half] star rating at the
top of this review is not for people who don't
like Downton Abbey, have never seen it, or
grew tired of watching it.
The rating is for die-hards...the kinds of
viewers who will, I suspect, turn this movie
into an unexpected smash."
Lo and behold, he was right, illustrating
that Downton Abbey knew its audience better
than perhaps any film of 2019.
"This is good.
I thought something else was planned, but
it is excellent.
So, a well done to old cuvay."
2019's most ambitious sci-fi drama saw an
astronaut journeying to the edge of the universe
to find his missing father.
If Ad Astra had fumbled its weighty premise
even the presence of Brad Pitt, one of Hollywood's
most bankable stars, might not have saved
it.
Fortunately, co-writer and director James
Gray largely stuck the landing, and Pitt assisted
with a performance that ranks among the best
in his career.
Ann Hornaday of The Washington Post praised
Pitt's performance while opining that the
visually impressive film's greatest strengths
lie in its themes.
She wrote:
"It's a terrific ride, yes, but also a provocative
meditation on masculinity, the things we choose
to cherish or squander, and other eternal
verities of life that swirl, unresolved, while
our little blue marble continues to spin."
The great Leonard Maltin had even more praise,
writing:
"James Gray is one of our foremost, and most
original, filmmakers.
We already knew that Brad Pitt is an exceptional
leading man but this performance burnishes
that reputation.
The film is among this year's very best."
You probably knew right off the bat whether
Good Boys would be your cup of tea, or, more
accurately, your can of cheap beer.
Still, for viewers who found the idea of a
trio of foul-mouthed tween boys stumbling
into a series of inappropriate situations
to be a formula for hilarity, the flick delivered,
big time.
Good Boys' young leads were roundly praised
for their charming performances in a movie
that served up a surprising amount of warmth
alongside its crass comedic sensibility.
Chicago Sun-Times critic and former Roger
Ebert cohort Richard Roeper wrote:
"Even the most hardcore jokes have a good-natured
and even sweet larger context...For all its
wacky, gross-out, shock-ya humor, Good Boys
has a lot of heart."
"It's not a good burn!
His dad has two DUIs and has to take the train
to work.
That's a good burn!"
It seems like only a matter of time before
the charismatic and hilarious Jillian Bell
achieves major stardom.
If the universe is a just place, Brittany
Runs a Marathon will be the final stop before
that destination.
The dramedy failed to set the box office on
fire, but it has all the makings of a future
cult classic: it's a sometimes hysterical,
sometimes heartfelt examination of what it
takes to achieve true self-improvement.
It's also anchored by a lead performance which
suggests that this was the role Bell had been
waiting for all her life.
As Michael Phillips of the Chicago Tribune
put it:
"The movie succeeds because Bell succeeds.
It's gratifying to see a so-called character
actress with reliably deadly comic timing
loosen up, stretch out and learn what it means
to carry a movie."
The cast of The Farewell won't be terribly
well-known to American audiences, with one
glaring exception: Awkwafina, the rapper-turned-actress
who has had perhaps a hotter two-year run
than anyone in Hollywood.
The dramedy deals with a large Chinese family
who throw together a wedding as an excuse
to get together when they discover that their
grandmother is dying.
Writer/director Lulu Wang puts her star through
her dramatic and comedic paces in service
of a film that deftly pulls off a trick which
is slowly starting to become more common in
Hollywood: telling a universally relatable
story from a specific cultural point of view.
The Farewell received near-universal praise,
with one common caveat: bring your tissues.
Total Film's Jamie Graham said:
"[It's] a film about family, with all of its
frets and foibles, fondness and fidelity.
It is heartfelt and beautifully observed,
so while everyone on screen is doing their
utmost to hold back tears, yours will come
unchecked."
Hustlers stars Jennifer Lopez as a veteran
stripper who trains her peers in the finer
points of her side job, drugging and ripping
off wealthy clients.
Taking place against the backdrop of the 2008
financial collapse, the film was hailed for
its smart writing and directing, and the amazing
chemistry of its cast.
Inkoo Kang of Slate called Hustlers:
"An immediate entrant into the pantheon of
female friendship movies [and] a pretty much
perfect film."
Many critics noted that those expecting a
pandering, empty exercise would be disappointed.
As FilmBunker's Ciaran Kerr wrote:
"What could have been a film weighed down
by its own agenda presented its main characters
as living, breathing, complex individuals,
shying away from the empty 'girl power' rhetoric
that a lot of Hollywood features try to feed
the masses as feminism.
Furthermore, it was entertaining and a pleasure
to watch."
The Lighthouse is a black-and-white period
piece in which two lighthouse operators slowly
lose their minds while stationed on an isolated
island.
The film ended up being a lot more entertaining
than that sounds, thanks in large part to
the committed performances of its leads, Robert
Pattinson and Willem Dafoe.
Adam Graham of Detroit News drew an interesting
comparison in his assessment of the film.
He said:
"The Lighthouse is a starkly gorgeous black-and-white
head trip that is like staring into a blinding
light: you're hypnotized, you can't look away
and your eyes won't be the same after."
"Let Neptune strike ye dead, Winslow!
HAAAAARK!'
Much had been written about The Irishman well
before its release, because the Netflix film
carries a pedigree unlike any other.
It's a late-career work from Martin Scorsese,
perhaps the greatest living film director,
which stars his longtime accomplices Robert
De Niro and Joe Pesci.
It's also got Al Pacino, with whom Scorsese
had never worked previously.
Finally, the film is based on the biography
of union leader Frank Sheeran, who is purported
to have had mob ties, and may have even killed
Jimmy Hoffa.
Critics welcomed it as an absolute tour de
force, one of Scorsese's best efforts in a
filmography full of masterpieces.
Rolling Stone's Peter Travers wrote:
"With The Irishman, America's greatest living
director creates his late-career masterpiece,
a deeply felt addition that vibrantly sums
up every landmark in his crime-cinema arsenal."
Veteran director James Mangold gave us a superhero
movie unlike any other with 2017's Logan,
and for his next trick, he decided to smoothly
shift gears into a period piece drama about
racecars and the men who drive them.
With Ford v Ferrari, Mangold had the added
bonus of working with Matt Damon and Christian
Bale, two acting masters at imbuing their
characters with layers of emotional complexity.
The resulting flick is a rousing historical
crowd-pleaser, with critics mostly agreeing
that the movie is every bit the well-oiled
machine that one would expect.
San Diego Reader's Matthew Lickona wrote:
"Mangold indulges himself with this tale of
American manhood, but he knows he can afford
it.
He's got Bourne and Batman as brilliant, brawling
best buds."
More than a few critics opined that the film
is a touch too long, but that the amazing
chemistry between Damon and Bale carries it
through its more draggy stretches.
Its overall reception was best summarized
by Quad-City Times' Linda Cook who succinctly
wrote:
"Ford v Ferrari is a great ride."
Tom Hanks appearing as Fred Rogers is about
the most spot-on piece of casting anyone could
have ever hoped for, and the biopic A Beautiful
Day in the Neighborhood makes good on that
potential.
At a time when we could all use a bit more
of the values that Rogers espoused, the movie
isn't content just to illustrate the late
children's show host's dedication to said
values.
Instead, it shows how those values inspired
everyone around him.
As RogerEbert.com's Monica Castillo, wrote:
"[The movie] isn't so much a biopic as it
is a way to look at the way Mr. Rogers affected
generations of children, young and grown.
If his character seems too simple, it's likely
because that's how many people saw him, uncomplicated
and confined to his on-screen persona...That's
the lasting power of Mr. Rogers."
Writer/director Rian Johnson wowed fans with
Knives Out, his inspired tribute to Agatha
Christie-style whodunits.
With an all-star cast including Chris Evans,
Daniel Craig, Jamie Lee Curtis, and Michael
Shannon, the flick won over critics with its
crackerjack writing and playfully devious
vibe.
Eugene Weekly's Molly Templeton said of the
film:
"Johnson's vision translates a love for classic
murder mysteries into a kaleidoscopic ensemble
piece that twists and spins, using the structure
and tropes of mystery, and comedy, to expose
the endless ways humans justify being absolutely
rotten to each other."
Real-life whistleblowers have long provided
fodder for excellent cinematic dramatizations,
from All the President's Men to Michael Clayton.
The Mark Ruffalo vehicle Dark Waters falls
squarely into that tradition, telling the
story of Robert Biliott, an attorney whose
20-year long pursuit of chemical corporation
DuPont upended his life in ways few could
imagine.
Directed by Oscar nominee Todd Haynes, the
film received critical kudos for spinning
an entertaining yarn from what could have
been the ingredients for a plodding procedural.
There was also plenty of praise for Ruffalo's
performance, which conclusively proves that
the actor is more than just a Hulk.
Richard Roeper of the Chicago Sun-Times wrote:
"Ruffalo is a master at playing a certain
type of earnest character who often wears
a quizzical expression, not because he's slow
on the uptake, but because he's the smartest
person in the room and he has questions no
one else has even thought to ask."
The film's true power was laid out nicely
by Dominic Griffin of Spectrum Culture:
"Dark Waters is special because it's not about
dramatically building to an inevitable victory,
but about the importance of fighting every
day anyway, knowing such a conclusion may
never come."
With any literary work that has been adapted
as many times as Louisa May Alcott's Little
Women, it's always worth asking if one more
is really necessary.
As illustrated by the 2019 adaptation, the
answer is yes, especially when an adaptation
is written and directed by Greta Gerwig, the
filmmaker behind the Oscar-nominated 2017
film Lady Bird.
Working with an all-star cast including the
likes of Saorise Ronan, Emma Watson, Florence
Pugh, Laura Dern, and Meryl Streep, Gerwig
delivered a timeless, open-hearted adaptation
that delighted long-time fans of the book
and new audiences alike.
Lisa Johnson Mandell of At Home in Hollywood
singled out how the latest telling differs
from all the rest, writing:
"Little Women should be promoted with director
Greta Gerwig's name in the title.
Her colorful, warm and creative touch is what
sets it apart from so many versions of the
story, and so many other gritty, violent and
tiresome films of the day.
It's simply a joy to watch."
The joy was definitely contagious; according
to Cinemayward's Joel Mayward:
"It's a warm hug of a film...Gerwig clearly
loves every one of these characters, and such
love flows from the screen to the audience
with generosity and grace."
That brothers Josh and Benny Safdie turned
in one of 2019's best isn't terribly surprising;
their previous feature was the underrated
Good Time, a harrowing thriller which conclusively
proved that star Robert Pattinson is the real
deal as an actor.
The surprise in Uncut Gems is Adam Sandler,
who stars as the gambling-addicted jewelry
store owner Howard Ratner.
Critics were simply mesmerized by his performance,
which has been greeted by nearly universal
acclaim.
The Sun-Times' Richard Roeper called the flick:
"Uncut Gems [is] one of the most authentic
deep-dives into the world of the gambling
addict ever put on film.
Adam Sandler's performance as a New York jeweler
with a variety of voracious appetites...ranks
right up there the work of Steve McQueen in
The Cincinnati Kid, Edward Norton and Matt
Damon in Rounders, George Segal and Elliott
Gould in California Split, and James Caan
in The Gambler."
Virtually all reviewers were stunned by Sandler's
work, and the supporting cast, which included
the likes of Lakeith Stanfield, Kevin Garnett,
and Idina Menzel, were no slouches, either.
Rob Dean of Daily Grindhouse arguably summed
it up best:
"Uncut Gems is the best panic attack you'll
have all year...a brilliant character study,
an engaging story of various lowlifes, and
one of the best films of 2019."
"This is me.
This is how I win."
When Joker was announced, it was easy to feel
like the flick was either going to be a disaster
or a masterpiece.
Once the trailers were released, it quickly
became clear that the flick would be his homage
to gritty '70s character studies in general,
and to the works of Martin Scorsese in particular.
Director Todd Phillips' ace in the hole, though,
was his star.
Joaquin Phoenix and Phillips diligently crafted
an intense portrait of a very disturbed man,
one which challenged the notion of what a
"comic book movie" could be.
Joker not only became the first R-rated film
to gross over a billion dollars worldwide,
but it received 11 Academy Award nominations
- more than any other 2019 movie.
It may have divided critics, but not so much
audiences, who by and large saw the film for
what it was: a masterclass in film studies,
with near-flawless acting, direction, and
editing, and the greatest pure character study
that's been put to film in decades.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.